far from the ocean at the edge of a
national park in northern Wales surfers
wait for the perfect wave at surf
snowdonia state-of-the-art technology
creates the world's longest man-made
surfing waves
it took years for Fernando or Drona's
company wave garden to figure out how to
create the perfect wave using a minimum
of energy it's making surfing accessible
there are very few places in the wor
what you can surf there are very few
places right now with these kind of
installations anybody in the world will
be able to surf a large underwater blade
pulled through the center of the lake
creates the artificial waves they can be
up to 2 meters high the technology is
similar to a ski lift
Odia fellows company first experimented
with the idea at a smaller site in
northern Spain where they also tested
surfing at night wave garden isn't the
only company that specializes in
man-made waves many have tried it but
gave it up due to high energy costs a
manufacturer in Scotland holds the
current record of creating waves over
three metres high but Fernando Audrey
Isola says size isn't everything
what makes unique our technology is is
the possibility of creating waves that
holds the size holds the power for a
long distance this is a SAG Award you
find in some point breaks in in this in
the surfing paradise like Indonesia or
Hawaii surf snowdonia provides lessons
and on-site accommodation a two-hour
beginner course costs around 55 euros
advanced surfers like P attic TN pay
around 64 euros an hour to surf the
waves it's a great way to get in some
practice but in the ocean the waves are
free and the experience is certainly
different what I'm missing the most is
the bonding with the nature this
interaction that it gives and takes at
the same time that feeling of freedom
when you're between the sea in the sky
is something you can't recreate but in
the ocean the surf sometimes gets too
rough or too weak pros like Casper dine
fats say installations like this could
also help establish surfing as an
Olympic discipline thing with competing
in the ocean is you're always at the
mercy of the conditions here in the wave
pool you can produce the same exact wave
again and again and again and that just
levels the playing field it's it's a is
a great possibility for competitions
especially when looking at the Olympic
campaign
at present the rain water filled Basin
is generating a wave every two and a
half minutes
eventually that interval will get
shorter
Pyrrhic 10 is watching the clock he
wants to get the most out of his visit
goes very quick this is something that I
want you to stay like for the next five
hours in here just to get more feel for
it and I guess more accustomed to it but
at the price of it
the effect and lives in Geneva
Switzerland soon he may not have to
travel so far to catch the perfect wave
wave garden is already building 20 other
facilities on all five continents we
think the ocean is the best and we
cannot replace the ocean
but we can we can bring ways where there
is no waves and then I think that's a
great combination combining the ocean
with with the man-made waves wave
Gardens next Park is due to open in the
u.s. in Austin Texas more than 2,000
kilometres from the Surfers Paradise on
the Pacific coast for Texas they're
planning even higher and longer waves
if wave garden has its way surf parks
will be the wave of the future